des services de réanimation qui ne
désemplissent pas tout comme les
terrasses de cafés de la capitale buenos
aires est ce celle étrange paradoxe qui
frappe la société argentine avec plus de
10000 morts et près de 480 8000 cas de
contamination le pays est l'un des plus
touchés par le coronavirus pourtant la
population semble lassée par plus de
cinq mois de mesures restrictives plus
ou moins souple un laisser-aller que
dénonce le personnel hospitalier
nous voyons les gens qui ne prennent pas
les précautions ou les mesures
nécessaires dehors et cela me rend cela
ne frustre parce que nous donnons tout
sur la ligne de front et c'est comme
s'ils s'en apercevait par des soignants
au bord du gouffre alors que les
services de réanimation ne cesse de se
remplir près de 62 % des lits sont
occupés sur le plan national
un chiffre qui monte à près de 68% dans
la région de buenos ars une situation
qui commence à devenir intenable pour de
nombreux médecins
l'épuisement se fait sentir l'épuisement
nous sommes ici du lundi au lundi
pendant 10 à 12 heures par jour et quand
nous rentrons à la maison
nous continuons avec les appels et les
recommandations la vérité c'est que
l'épuisement se fait un peu sentir nous
y mettons tout notre coeur nos collègues
tombe malade
c'est de plus en plus difficile de tout
couvrir nous voyons de plus en plus de
malades et nous sommes vraiment épuisé
sans pause sans repos c'est une lutte
qui nous épuise touché psychologiquement
et physiquement pas mannequin un
contexte sanitaire inquiétant qui a mis
l'économie argentine en grande
difficulté le fonds monétaire
international devrait fournir un nouveau
prêt de plusieurs milliards de dollars à
buenos aires est ce si les négociations
commencées la semaine dernière
aboutissent une perfusion financière
vitale la dette publique de l'argentine
s'élève à près de 3 124 milliards de
dollars soit près de 90 pour cent de son
produit intérieur brut